julien sauvage est bonjour vous nous
avez rejoint pour nous parler maintenant
de la situation militaire dans ce qui
désormais peut être rappeler la bataille
de kiev qu'est ce qu'on sait que c'est
ont précisément maintenant d'avancer des
troupes russes ou alors on va revenir
grâce à une carte sur cette situation
tout débute bien sûr hier avec le début
de cette de cette offensive des troupes
qui était massé des troupes russes qui
étaient massés en biélorussie et qui
vont donc traversé la frontière à l'est
jusqu'à
tchernobyl qui vont être qui va être
prise dès hier soir une information
confirmée à la fois par les forces
l'ukrainienne et par les forces russes
depuis tchernobyl ces deux divisions
cela représente environ entre
une division c'est entre 10 et 30 mille
soldats là il ya deux divisions qui sont
en train de descendre rapidement jusque
kiev elles ont atteint d'ailleurs kiev
depuis ce matin on a confirmation que
ses troupes notamment des blindés sont
positionnés à une dizaine de kilomètres
seulement de la capitale alors que il y
a déjà des combats dans la banlieue de
kiev est désormais dans les rues de kiev
je vous propose une deuxième carte pour
essayer de mieux comprendre on va aller
un petit peu plus près pour mieux voir
la voilà nous sommes dans cette région
ce matin nous avons confirmation de
plusieurs attaques qui ont été menées de
plus dans ces affrontements qui ont été
menées entre les forces ukrainienne et
les forces russes notamment à yvan kif
d'izmir donc 80 km depuis la capitale
entre kiev et inventif d'izmir seulement
45 km et puis il y à cet aéroport cet
aéroport de ce tome elle qui est un
aéroport de fret mais dont russes et
ukrainiens tentent de prendre le
contrôle une première attaque hier les
russes ont réussi à le prendre ensuite
les ukrainiens ont contre-attaqué réussi
à le reprendre depuis ce matin des
combats ils font toujours rage on ne
sait pas exactement à l'heure actuelle
qui tient cet aéroport évidemment très
important cette position pour évidemment
l'entrée à kiev mais dans kiev et ça le
président et la demie l'a indiqué il y a
déjà des troupes russes qui sont
présentes dans la ville nous avons
plusieurs rapports qui nous disent aussi
qu'il y à des combats qui sont engagés
dans les rues notamment et là je vous
pose un troisième carton valait un petit
peu plus près encore on va zoom et un
peu plus on va se rendre voilà
directement dans qu'est ce que vous
voyez ici et voilà des premiers
affrontements ont été reportés à auburn
ce qui dans le nord de kiev des
explosions ont été signalés à plusieurs
endroits dans la capitale mais ici il
s'agit de troupes paramilitaires
parachutistes des troupes d'avancer
qu'ils font déjà une première percée le
but l'habillement poutine l'a dit c'est
de décapiter l'état ukrainien le
gouvernement donc d'attraper le
président zelazny président a dit james
key the new skies pardon qui qui lui a
indiqué qu'il voulait rester la france a
par contre elle indiqué qu'elle était
prête à l'évacuer s'il le fallait la
france qui a des troubles du gène qui
sont positionnés ici aussi pour protéger
l'ambassade de france merci